[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now we've
made some progress and by some progress
and means we we did the sex again okay
so now we get to go around and say hi to
everyone else so I don't know who is
next on my list and I don't know why I
need to make it so creepy like that and
see that I have a list of girls that I
need to go through but I do believe that
Q would be the next one cuz she's
already at 4 so tonight's gonna be
something okay
I like you know look at you you're so
adorable let's go on a date you and I I
know it does thank you thank you very
much okay so I guess from the
perspective of how many other girls
there are left it's gonna be a couple
more episodes system get through the
game something I had something very
profound to say but I've totally
forgotten what it was
[Music]
yeah there we go I still got it even
though I went with belly and I did the
thing that people do in the dark I I've
not lost my skill I took a little bit of
a break there because whoa man I have no
idea how come this is gonna be censored
but it is what it is so the only thing
that I'm dreading is ending up with Momo
and getting that done I'm gonna put that
on the very end of the shelf and I have
some new text so I'm assuming this is
good dude I found your mega stash bah ha
ha ha
hope you don't mind that I borrowed a
few of the good ones oh oh put tiny
censorship on that that's horrible stop
that it's my sins - I knew my Celestin
lust 'is nightclub well we're about to
find out a celestial alien broad show
your face show your face I was baking
some cupcakes and I got batter all over
the place who's gonna help me clean it
up huh
oh whoa ok anyway moving on now so bye
oh man
there there is I know this there is an
uncensored version of this game believe
it or not not just the censorship that
I've put in but there's an uncensored
version with like more gratuitous nudity
but that's not available on Steam so all
of you have to deal with that my
goodness are you doing would you like it
swimmers cap how are you gonna fit it
around your horns Oh a gift for a girl
who doesn't mind getting a little wet
alrighty then
you're welcome yes what do you have oh
my I'm smart I know what I do I just I
pressed the wrong button
yes what cup size you rocking more like
a cup full of lies there's no way you're
double D you're like a G or an effort
something like that not that I know I
have no experience in this department
let's go on a date shut up I did not
know that I'm not psycho like you I
don't know that I'm an earth man but I
am the world's greatest human lover and
soon to be world greatest alien lover
well let me tell you all about Earth and
all about Earth wonderful earthing
excuse my spit
hey okay I did it
man I'm getting down to the wire on
these ones it's getting harder and
harder and harder but I'm gonna get
congratulations go go you so this is
getting really hard because if I keep
going on the dates that it's just gonna
get harder and harder than exponentially
harder and I only have so many upgrades
that I'm gonna be able to do so I've got
a singularity what does that mean
singularity oh I like the hyperdrive one
just to be perfect that's really weird
why is that I don't care q it's time to
meet Q it's time for Q yes but you said
I can't any time he said only at night
your species is nocturnal
I remember what you tell me okay bye
hello I sure AM Celeste escaped my
prison cell aboard the laddoo Federation
mothership proceeded to kill everything
oh oh gosh well what why do you why do
you have nipple clamps why do you have
nipple clamps on your outfit why are you
wearing a BDSM bodysuit why why okay
alright then I'll just be on my way with
my date with the ferry and everything
will be okay I got something
yeah you do like to walk around in your
underwear so that is a good thing about
you I guess
nothing okay let's go on a date you
egotistical maniac I sure will
I've got the best puzzle skills even
though you taught me how to do that I
[Music]
prematurely celebrated but that problem
will come up later don't you worry oh
[Music]
well okay that couldn't have been more
dry indirect is that how the rest of
this night is gonna go because frankly
I'm not gonna participate
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes yes put that good
did that do it did that do it for you
how about that how about them apples
yeah what am I talking about I don't
know frankly I don't know what's going
on
at least I know I don't have to teach
you anything about that uh-huh Thanks I
wouldn't have taken your advice I'm a
professional I am known by myself as I
have told myself as I was hearkened by
the alien that I was given the device by
you from giving you a dirty magazine
that I am the world's greatest human
lover and alien lover and fairy okay all
right time to keep going I guess
Sep suits not over yet that's how are
you shorty yeah I thought you were one
of the tiny itty bitty ones but I guess
that wouldn't mean doing the dance of
the naughty bits
whoa awkward I don't think I could have
said that more awkwardly but it doesn't
matter right now
you just said how stupid do you think I
am you're not a pixie oh nothing
apparently you I'm going to go say hi
too low I won't wait is Lola Lola might
be because if Lola is whoa I'll come
back to you baby but I'm gonna talk to
you first
um I think Oh Celeste is available I
definitely want to talk to Celeste my
sleeves
I made Slave Leia my god I cannot talk
oh yeah you never expect the Spanish
Inquisition surprised you got this
this is a peculiar thing it sure is
that's a goof Oh as they call it in the
human circles they don't call it that
do you want a mango eggplant
oh you don't addict plant a mango
eggplant
I know I know you can't I got it
accidentally I already have an eggplant
I got to an air glance where's the
tissue why do I have a tissue box Who am
I trying to give this tissue box to you
want to soak up your food I would be
roughly the equivalent of your July 20th
wait how in what spectral universe does
the stars align to make that possible
how do you know that anything you'd like
to know about yes what is wrong with you
we sure do that's all I am four point
something billion 4.5 billion all right
those bars let's go on a date tonight no
mark oh it is going to be such an
enjoyable time let us go let us go
wha-ho Slave Leia okay anyway enough
excitement out of me that's uh maintain
our air of professionalism not as
impressive as that five combo would be
and not as impressive as if I would have
said impress it correctly but let's
count our chickens before they hatch
[Music]
well if you know about the next day then
you know what's going on but don't worry
I'm gonna save that for later I'm gonna
save that for a good dad it's not gonna
be good damn up until that point I'm
gonna I'm gonna go now I'm gonna go i'ma
go and I think I need to meet up all
right goodbye I'm off to flirt with
another human girl but don't feel
inferior you will always have a special
place in my heart we were supposed to
meet up alright let's go wait I got a
picture attacked by another tentacle
monster of course it's not all bad
though you kind of get used to it hard
face why that's not this is supposed
team is supposed to be the uncensored
version Oh just pour it all good god
well not uh but you know what I mean I
just you know let's go then we need to
finish this night off strong because
it's been a little weird just a little
weird with aliens and tentacles well
that's lovely it's better than your two
strings that was your bikini but I'm not
complaining I am not complaining
it is giving them nothing nothing Jesus
[Music]
be with the girl in the night under the
covers that was my Rae dance I'm going
to do the dance of Zechs anyway excuse
me I have to match them things let me
just think about this for a long time oh
yeah those are colorful I bet I could
match those right up oh I can make so
many matches out of that oh ok anyway
I'm gonna go now women these days always
wanting to take their clothes off I just
want to solve a puzzle Jesus it's a hard
one this is us
Oh baby yes that's real nice that's nice
whatever's going on over there oh well
we're done mark I want you to give me
lots of Venice please I love having
cybersex oh yeah hey Adam huh well I
imagine if that was uncensored that'd be
entirely obscene but as of right now
it's totally okay and family-friendly in
fact so there you go oh oh
so thank you everybody so much for
watching you got a twofer on this
episode and on the next episode I'll do
more things to embarrass myself and make
my mom not proud to watch these videos
play hi mom
are you proud of me yet sorry hope
you're not bothered to thank you okay
thanks mom for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next one mom bye bye
[Music]